hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
as a landlord and property investor for
13 years one of the things that
sometimes happens is tenants that you
have to evict and in this video i'm
going to be talking about all the rules
and regulations section 21 section 8 how
to get rid of tenants how to do it the
legal way what to avoid doing and also
i'm going to be reacting to begin with
to a landlord who tried to evict his
tenants in a very unorthodox way and
we're going to be discussing this and
i'm going to be telling you exactly how
to do it legally so let's watch the
video this is only my second time
watching it so let's see what happens
yeah
because i wasn't sure it was going to
sell anything you should be inviting
people
this is absolutely ludicrous i had a
vibe for this house i can honestly tell
you
when i first fantasized to you i didn't
know i was going to sell it i've had an
offer on the house it's an offer i can't
refuse and the house is sold so surely
we signed the contract that says that
we're going to look here
in the contract so you've got a licky
you've not signed a contract they say
you can't you can't leave at any time
i'd decide
what they were supposed to do like two
weeks nowadays that's ridiculous aren't
they well that's not my problem i'm
sorry
it's not my problem
this is your problem
i can't believe that the landlord is
there shouting saying this is your
problem not my problem given trying to
give two weeks notice i mean i don't
know what kind of tenancy they're on but
if they're on a standard ast contract
then this is
completely illegal and unacceptable and
also quite threatening behavior from the
landlord
he's right they wouldn't say no way they
would say at least two months notice so
it sounds to me like the tenants haven't
they don't quite know the the legalities
or the law but they just know that this
doesn't seem right the fact that a
landlord can come and just say out in
two weeks just just just doesn't feel
right to them and they're absolutely
correct it's completely wrong are you
gonna show them the contract have you
got the contract yeah well yeah what is
your contract
what does the contract say the contract
does not fail to give you six weeks
notice this house is now sold people
will be moving in here in the next two
weeks and you can't be well what happens
if the daughter's moving
yeah
well you you will move forward
he doesn't know the answer he's just
like oh wow you will the police will be
i mean even if they're not on a standard
ast contract unless they're on something
like um you know guest terms of high
which it doesn't sound like they are
earlier in the video they said that
they've just moved all the stuff in paid
like all for their furniture moved in so
no matter what contract they're on they
still do have tenants rights if it's
their home they they are protected by
the law and i just i don't know what
this landlord is thinking i just i can't
believe that i'm even hearing
this fish water isn't it
so now again the tenants are kind of
being pushed into into a corner and
they're like even squatters have got
more rights than this and he's he think
it's aggressive you bring it on then
like absolutely unprofessional can't
believe what i'm watching right now you
bring it on you can't just keep this out
of here yes i can
you say you're gonna help ran people at
house and then just to say two weeks
later that you're gonna say
exactly and that contract does not say i
have to give you six seven eight nine
ten weeks notice no this isn't right
no i hope the contract
actually according to uh standard law
and all ast contracts if you move a
tenant in you can't kick them out within
four months of moving them in because
they're on a they'll be on a fixed a
fixed term so i
really feel bad for the tenants i hope
this doesn't get any worse
how could it be wrong because you moved
them in two weeks ago and now you're
telling them that they have to go with
zero notice on like
how can it be this landlord is so
selfish and just can't empathize for
anybody apart from his situation
absolutely shocking
how can you tell me what i can and
cannot do with my house
because it's their home yes it's your
house but it's their home and they are
protected by the law and have rights as
human beings in a home
goodness i came here in in all good
i
my
faith to try and give you as much notice
as i possibly possible
two weeks
detail then they can't move in for a
couple of months
[Music]
the way he says like they're just
i don't know if tenants like this guy
this is why
landlords and property investors need
some basic education before you know you
don't need any training or
any license generally in in england to
become a landlord but maybe you should
because you have people like him that
don't know the law that give us a bad
name so i've waited until that
contract's been signed
let me just mention that yeah no i'm
sorry but you're not part of my business
oh
what
you're not part of my business
aren't they
the people that give you your income
that is they're your customers man
i need to sit down with this landlord
and have some a serious conversation bam
i don't have to consider i think he said
i'm not your father i know that i say my
father
well that's great bring you don't take
in the contract there's nothing in that
contract that gives you rights to stay
here for weeks and weeks and weeks and
weeks or spot in here until you decide
that you want to make some money
i really want to see what this contract
is i mean it sounds to me like
the tenants aren't really sure they
don't know what they've signed and he's
just sort of taken advantage because i i
really don't know what this contract is
but if what he's saying is correct then
the contract that he's using isn't legal
anyway
[Music]
[Music]
and you've got people living in there
it's their home house about a little bit
of communication completely selfish
because he was worried that if he told
them he was selling it they'd move out
and he didn't want to lose rent so he
just thought i'm going to say nothing
keep the rent right up until the point
when it's sold and then i'm just going
to force them out with the zero notice
two weeks absolutely shocking and i'm
gonna tell you that we're gonna leave
because we paid our rent so we have our
right to live here you've paid your rent
you've paid your rent to the end of the
month which is in two weeks time and
that's when you need to okay well i
think you should leave so we can get
some advice on this song
we need to have another conversation
because this is going to happen it is
going to go ahead so you just need to
get your heads right there i appreciate
it it's not good news for you but it is
going to go ahead you haven't got a left
to stand up i'm afraid legally or
illegally if you decide to squat you
haven't got a leg to stand up you will
be out of this property within two weeks
okay
okay
i think the tenants did the right thing
just saying to him look i think you
should leave so okay whilst that is
completely unprofessional and wrong what
are the actual laws how do you get rid
of tenants um and and how should the
landlord have conducted himself so
there's different ways that you can ask
tenants to leave if they're on a
standard normal contract ast contract
which stands for assured short hold
tenancy agreement usually when they move
in they'll be on a minimum fixed term of
six months now you can't break that
within that six months no matter what
happens if you decide to sell the house
you cannot ask your tenants to leave in
that fixed term now after that fixed
term you can ask them to leave you can
ask them to leave if they're not if
they're behind on their rent then you
can evict them with something called a
section eight if there's no reason at
all you just want the house back you
want to move back into it you want to
sell the house then you need to evict
them on something called a section 21
notice so what is a section 21 notice
how do you use it so a section 21 notice
is an eviction notice that you're going
to give to your tenants which means that
they have to move and you don't need a
reason for this so for instance if
they're not paying rent or if they're
being a nuisance or if they've damaged
the property then you're going to serve
them on a section 8. now section 21 you
have to give two months notice for them
to leave so for example let's say you've
got some tenants they've been there a
couple of years they want a monthly roll
in contracts they're paying their rent
they love the property and you just
decide that you want your house back or
you decide that you want to sell the
house it's their home
so you can't just throw them out you
have to give two months notice and you
have to also do it properly so this is
when a section 21 doesn't apply so
number one if it's less than four months
since the tenancy started or the fixed
term has not ended unless there's a
clause in the contract which allows you
to do this now i don't know what kind of
clause he might have had in the contract
but still i'm sure he was breaking a
whole bunch of these rules because i'm
going to continue next if the properties
are hmo and you've not got a license in
place
if the tenancy started after april 2007
and you've not put the tenant's deposit
in a deposit protection scheme so if you
take a deposit off of a tenant you need
to make sure that you register that
deposit with some with a company like my
deposit stock code at uk this will cost
about 30 pounds and if you don't do this
the tenant can use it against you when
you try and get rid of them they can
refuse to leave they can actually fine
you which three times of the deposit so
make sure if you take a deposit off of a
tenant you get that deposit registered
next if the tenancy started after
october 2015 and you've not used a form
sa or a letter with all the same
information on it so when you evict them
you need to give them something called a
form sa you can get this from the
council website and you can find these
online and this is just a list of things
that you need to make sure you can't
just turn up to the property and go
here's your two months notice or text
them and say you need to move like two
weeks you need to fill out a proper
eviction form so that every all the all
everything's all covered in it and
they've got all the information that
they need this is really important and a
lot of landlords don't realize they have
to do this next if the council has
served an improvement notice on the
property in the last six months so if
there's something really bad with the
property and the council have asked for
something to be updated or if the
council has served a notice in the last
six months that says it will do
emergency works on the property and
lastly if you've got
if you have not repaid any unlawful fees
or deposits that you charged the tenant
so
anything any of those reasons why you're
trying to serve a section 21 um if
you're not complying with these reasons
then the tenant can just ignore you
you'll then take them to court and you
will lose because of these points also
if the tenant hasn't received a copy of
one of these three things you can't a
victim number one an energy performance
certificate
next a how to rent guide and finally a
gas safety certificate so you if you've
got a management company who's managing
the property make sure that the
management company gives the tenant
those three things they need to have
received them you need to be able to
prove that the tenant has received them
maybe if you send an email or something
like that or you have an epc certificate
on the wall and you can show it's on the
wall take a picture of it on the
inventory so as long as you are above
above board as a landlord you've got
everything up to date you've registered
the deposits and you fill out an sa form
then you can get rid of a tenant within
two months notice by filling out the
form and asking them to leave so that's
how you should do it properly i hope
this video was super helpful if you
don't like the idea of tenants and you
think man i'd love to be able to buy a
property and rent it out but without
having all of the red tape of having to
evict tenants
i'll say this number one this is not a
bad thing it's good that tenants have
rights because it is their home and it
wouldn't be right if you could just go
like this landlord did and say off you
go two weeks out out of my house i don't
care about you that's not really fair on
people that have got jobs lives kids
work
but secondly what you can do instead is
you can have something called guests now
if you want to buy a property and you
want to rent it out on shortstaylets on
airbnb and booking.com the advantage of
doing this is that your tenants are not
your tenants they are your guests and
they don't have rights if these tenants
were guests the landlord would have done
nothing wrong that clearly wasn't the
case they clearly weren't guests their
attendance another great thing about
having guests is you get a much higher
rent so a lot of my properties i don't
have tenants i have guests if you want
to learn about how to do that through
service accommodation check out this
video right here if you enjoyed the
video hit like drop your thoughts below
i look forward to reading and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you